pas un jour ne passe sans que son nom ne
divise un peu plus la gauche le rappeur
français made in de son vrai nom made in
the wish invité ce jeudi aux universités
d'été d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et de
la France insoumise c'est retrouver au
cœur d'une polémique après des propos
jugés antisémites dans un tweet publié
début août ce musicien engagé et proche
d'une partie de la nuque avec qualifié
l'essayiste Rachel Kahn de Ray scan B
alors que cette dernière est juive et
petite fille de déportée de quoi semer
le trouble au sein des vers dans
plusieurs élus ont choisi de boycotter
l'événement pour s'opposer à la venue du
rappeur on a cherché le buzz on l'a eu
de la pire des manières possibles on ne
badine pas avec l'antisémitisme l'ancien
Premier ministre est maire du Havre
Édouard Philippe également invité aux
universités d'été qui se dérouleront
dans sa ville à lui aussi refuser de s'y
rendre ce mercredi Médine est revenu sur
ses propos c'est une erreur je le
reconnais c'est un tweet maladroit car
je n'avais pas en tête l'histoire de sa
famille l'antisémitisme est un poison je
le combat depuis longtemps mais le
rappeur controversé n'a pas l'intention
d'abandonner dénonçant un traitement
médiatique démesuré il a maintenu sa
venue au Havre et il débattra pendant
une quinzaine de minutes avec la
secrétaire nationale d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts marines Tondelier j'ai accepté
l'invitation des verres pour faire
communiquer des mondes qui ne se parlent
plus le monde populaire dont je suis
originaire et la politique ce roman
médiatique est politique n'est pourtant
pas une première pour se musicien
d'origine algérienne au 1,5 millions
d'abonnés sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
son premier album de 2004 titré 11
septembre récits du 11e jour et taxé
d'apologie de Ben Laden par Alain
Finkielkraut ce Havrais de 40 ans à
enchaîner les propos provocateurs dont
il cultivent sciemment l'ambiguïté en
2014 made in post sur Facebook une photo
de lui dans les locaux de la radio
Skyrock faisant une quenelle geste à
connotation antisémite lancé par
l'humoriste controversé Dieudonné le
chanteur défendra par la suite un simple
geste anti-système qui aurait été
instrumentalisé par les récupérateurs
mais c'est la parution en janvier 2015
de son titre don't like qui fait
scandale
très bientôt ces paroles critiques sur
la laïcité à la française prenne une
toute autre résonance si jour après la
sortie du clip les frères Kouachi
pénètrent dans l'immeuble de Charlie
Hebdo et commettent un massacre au nom
de l'islam radical là encore made in
avait défendu ses positions en invoquant
l'expression d'une liberté
intellectuelle je me revendique de cet
esprit outrancier satirique au nom de la
liberté d'expression pour pouvoir
blasphémer une valeur lorsqu'elle est
dévoyée en juin 2018 son projet de
concert au Bataclan déclenche un nouveau
tollé à droite trois ans après les
attentats dans la salle de concerts
parisienne ces appels à crucifier les
leicars serait un sacré lèche pour les
victimes et un déshonneur pour la France
s'insurge alors le président des
républicains Laurent Wauquiez c'est des
tracteurs rappellent également sa
proximité avec l'association le havre de
paix accusé d'être proche des Frères
musulmans le rappeur assume d'ailleurs
sa sympathie pour tariq Ramadan
prédicateur musulman controversé taxé
tour à tour d'antisémitisme de misogynie
ou encore de communautarisme le rappeur
made in s’est aussi attirer les
critiques du milieu LGBT dans une vidéo
diffusée par plusieurs associations il
s'en prend au concept d'assimilation
pratiquée en Europe selon lui le
musulman européen serait un musulman
light qui fait un peu [__] la
députée écologiste Sandrine Rousseau a
sur pourtant que le rappeur a évolué sur
les questions des personnes LGBT les
mécanismes d'oppression qui frappent les
populations
lgbtqi+ sont les mêmes que les
mécanismes qui s'exercent sur les
populations racisées musulmanes et
féministes et qu'il faut combattre
ensemble a-t-il récemment confié au
Figaro en dosant la lutte contre les
différentes formes d'oppression chair
aux partisans de LFI depuis la parution
de l'album made in France en novembre
dernier celui qui a appelé à voter
Mélenchon au premier tour de la
présidentielle cette illustré sur le
front social en participant à plusieurs
mobilisations contre la réforme des
retraites une recule l'âge de la
retraite mais avant l'âge de la mort
[Musique]